Hey, Will, good to see you. Oh, hey. Look, I brought a friend today. His name's Sean. Hey. Oh, hi. Hey, guys. Yeah.
Sean, Jason kind of looks like he's, like, on the East Coast. Like, he's in Vermont or something, doesn't he? He does. I thought the trees in his window. It's so pretty. You know, that is something somebody asked me the other day about, well, why don't we have a video component to this? Right.
And I said, well, we thought about that. But then we thought, well, maybe we might not book people quite as easily because they might think, oh, I'm going to be on cameras and they don't want to get all made up. Yeah. Let's just do voices. Yeah. Yeah. Smartness.
You don't have to look pretty. You just have to sound pretty. Why? Welcome to the Pretty Pretty Tones. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's do our next voice. Let's. I want to ask you something. Last night, Scotty and I were sitting on the couch and we watched TV. And.
Huh. Whoa. Hang on a second. Let me just write this down. You guys were watching from the couch watching TV last night. I want to mark the date. Oh, hang on. I marked it yesterday and the day before that.
Yeah. And the day before that. That's our class time. Oh, there you go. And we're sitting there watching, and we're watching either, you know, Flora, Bama, Shor or a million dollar listing or project runway. Do you guys feel yourselves getting smarter? Yeah, about a minute.
And I have to stop and ask a lot of questions because I'm very curious. He got so upset with me. He's like, he turned to me and he's like, don't ask me to stop recording, like stop the TV again. We were in the middle. He gets so angry 10 minutes later. He stopped.
Hang on. I just need to, as people say unpack this, I don't like using that term just cause. It's kind of fun. Everybody uses it. It's the same with like, you see what I did there? Shut up. So you're going to unpack this.
So here, let me just say this. So you're not just, you're not happening upon these Florida, Obama shores or whatever it is. You're DVRing these things. Oh, for sure. Okay. Yeah.
Oh, for sure. Well, you know, we all have a mutual friend that goes one step further and we'll pause just, I'm sure that there's no paint left on that button, but she also has a laser pointer. For the bachelor and bachelorette. So once it's paused and mystery guest knows what the hell I'm talking about.
Once it's paused, the laser pointer goes up, things are circled, things are pointed out. I love that. Help assist with the comments or really mostly questions. Sean, you like that. I love that. That's how you watch TV. Do you watch TV more for the questions?
Is that your big, are you just in it for the questions? Yeah, for sure. No, I love that. I love that laser pointer thing. Oh, I know who that is. Okay, got it. That has been a guest. Yes.
Yeah. Okay, we'll let listener figure that out. But meanwhile, meanwhile, gang, we got a queen on the show today. Oh yeah? Yeah, she's a queen of movies, the queen of kindness, professionalism, real estate, hospitality and friendship.
Oh, she lived her first 12 years in Germany and Austria, spoke only German, ate only schnitzel and wore only braids. She then came to the stage, she made some movies, won some awards, a lot of them. She won an Oscar, a Globe, couple sags, three critics choice awards, three more, she'll tie our net and time named her most influential.
People named her most beautiful. Louie and Lila call her mom. We call her a great friend for saying yes to smart listen. Listener, you call her the one and only Sandra Bullock. Sandy. Oh, look at, she held that flag up though. Are your arms killing you? You guys need to land the plane.
Who would have gotten a C stand for you in there somewhere? My boot was the C stand. They brought one in, I didn't realize you guys would be in this holding pattern over LAX. Well, you're in a mess of trouble with it, all the different locals that you're not in right now. Yeah, you can't hold, you can't Hollywood your own stand, your own flag.
Sorry. How's the junket going? Listener, she's at a junket. She's promoting- You're literally at a junket. I'm at a junket. She's promoting the- Hi guys. Well, first of all, hello. Hi. Hi.
Yeah, Jason, hi, let us say hi. Jason, I have Amanda as my lifeline on the phone, so should you give me any problems? You have her on speaker right now? No, she's on my phone and she's sitting by, standing by with her phone just in case I should need her. In case you get some really probing question from us incredible journalists.
I like a probe. Yeah, we got it, thank you for the interview. You knew that. We got the quote, there it is. Hey, so how's the junket going forward, the unforgivable, which looks incredible? Yes. It's so far so good.
I mean, I haven't spoken to anyone- Are you in the middle of it? Yeah, at the beginning of it. So I just have to relearn how to speak to adults and people that I don't know other than- Wrong place. The living under my house and your wife and your children. That's all I've seen in two years.
Well, there's no adults here and you know how the junkets go. There's very few adults there in a good way. Wait, I wanna ask you something right off the bat because this movie looks good and everything. How do you go about choosing what seems to be always the right project? That's not true. That's stuff.
But it's, from this side, it always does. You know, like, I don't know. This came to me and when I read it, it reminded me of things that I learned when I was on my journey with my daughter to find my daughter. And it just is the more I researched, the more I learned about-
That's a- Go ahead and go through. Go ahead and go through. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm blowing some leaves. Obviously they ordered some food where I was and it's not for me. You go ahead and go that way. Thank you so much.
What's on there? There's a guy rolling it. Jason, guess what's on there? It's a charcuterie. Oh my God. Nothing made me happier than setting up the charcuterie when Jason would come because he loved his meats and I would roll them out in the cheeses.
In cheeses, meats and cheeses. And then he went vegan. Just as we're talking to, as we're talking to Sandy, somebody behind her rolled out right behind her. It's a huge plate. People can't see that. Hotel catering cart. Yeah, no, nobody can put together a charcuterie,
slab of wood like you. It's kind of sweet, right? It's great. It's kind of sweet. That's what you brought back from Germany and Austria. The meat, you know, you're kind of right? Yeah. Because you eat a lot of meats for breakfast,
a lot of sliced meats. Bratwurst. Bratwurst and Brezen. Those European breakfast buffets and you've got like all this stuff for everybody and then for the- I don't know where you were where there were buffets. You've never been to a buffet?
In Europe? We just had it at home. We just had it at home. My aunt in Germany. I like a European breakfast buffet. Come on, are you kidding? I'd never had a buffet there. Listen, let me just say this.
I listen, I'm relatable to the people to our listeners. They get it. They get me, I live a very relatable life. Hey, before we leave Austria, do you remember anything from Austria or Germany that's fond? I didn't know that. My family's still there.
My whole side of my, the cousins that I was raised with, my aunt and uncle, the house that we grew up in. It's all there. Do you still know how to speak German? Yeah, I speak German. Wait, wait, how about, how about it's a pleasure to be with you today?
But it's not good for me. Come on. It's not good for me. It doesn't make me happy that I'm here with you. I think it's the funniest- I love it. language. I love it so much.
I know there's nothing, you can try to soften it to make it more appealing. Say something passionate. Say something passionate in German. Like is dein Arschloch. You know what she just said, Jason? She said she'd like to build a bunker under her house and lock you in it for two years.
Wow, it's a few words. I said you are an asshole. Now, while you were over there, mom was singing in the opera guys, okay? She was an opera singer. And did you, can you sing? No. No.
At all. Because Amanda, who's father is a singer, she can't sing. I think it skips a generation. Lila, my daughter, has pipes like you would not. So it skipped me and landed on Lila. But both my parents were opera singers and then subsequently voice teachers. And I have no, we're really musical in the household.
We're just love music, dance, all that kind of stuff. But I just- Did you learn operas when you were younger? Did you- I was in them. I can hum any opera. I was in, you know, there's always a dirty child in every opera.
And I was usually the dirty child, the extras. A babysitting service for my mother. Do you know any of the music from promises, promises? Have you ever heard of this? Sure don't. Sure don't. I don't know if it's an opera. Is that a good one?
That's Sean's fastball. Doesn't really feel like an opera that was born out of the classics. Sean? Not even close. Now, when you were over there and you're following mom around as the dirty kid, did you have dreams of Hollywood and acting
or was that just something that happened once you came over on the, on the stewardship? I think I was always a hand bone, you know? I was always writing scripts and making the neighbors, you know, I think it was a way to meet guys. I mean, we had many boys in the neighborhood. So I was like, I'll write a script and they'll have to be in it.
And they all turned out like me. They all turned out like me. This is once you were in the States or still in Germany? This is in the States. In Germany, there, well, the schools in Germany are incredibly artistic. I went to a Waldorf school.
So they have a, the arts were just very prevalent. But I didn't at that point. They had a breakfast buffet? They had a meat buffet. It had a big, they had an incredible, it had a school buffet, sorry. Shetty balls. Is that what?
Shetty, yeah, yeah, yeah. We love the Shetty's. Now, okay, so then it was kind of a way to... Is this really interesting for you, Jason? Because it's funny that you're asking me questions about my life. These are things I can't ask you when we're over the charcoery board.
I don't know any of this. Do you really care? I guess who else cares? The listener cares. I could talk you about the opera thing for three hours. Were you in Carmen by any chance? I wasn't, but I could talk to you about yours and Scotty's little lip-syncing
that you guys need to pick up again. Please, dear God. I almost ended in a divorce. I hope they don't. I call that the unforgivable when they do that. What is that? I don't know anything about that. They lip-synced and he'd come up with a cowbell
and he'd go back down in the little maracas and it was the sweetest. It was so sweet and so special. Thank you, my dear. And funny and so well choreographed. And we almost got you in one and then we couldn't figure it out. I know, but I would have ruined it.
I wouldn't have done what you guys, there's just a charm that you guys just, you were so in sync and I would have out of synced it. You're very sweet. Jay, we did a bunch of like silly stupid dumb lip-sync videos. Look it up. It's so good. Yeah, and so good.
This was filmed. This was filmed, yeah. It wasn't in our house. Phone, yeah, in our house. It's stupid, it's stupid. But it kind of blew up and it got like hundreds and hundreds of millions. Did it blow up?
It was crazy. Yeah, it was. This sensation. Otherwise, when did you fit it in between TV viewings? Like, how did you get the time? While we were watching TV. It was in the room with the pocket doors. That's right.
That's in the next room over. All right, wait, I want to keep this thing on the rails. So we're in Hollywood and we're approaching employment and dating and all of that stuff. That started in New York. I was East Coast when it started. All right. Wait, wait, wait, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Let's back up. Can you move from Germany to the US? We would go back and forth based on the opera seasons and we lived between Salzburg, as it's said in English, and then Nuremberg. And when my mother would travel, I'd live with my cousins and my grandmother and my aunt and go to German school there.
Okay, so wait, you lived in Salzburg for a while? It's the most beautiful place I've ever lived. It's so beautiful. Well, the land of Mozart. It is, yeah. Wasn't Beethoven born there too, I think, perhaps? No, that was, that's Mozart, Mozart. I get them so confused.
Yeah. I like them both. We're gonna get lots of comments on this, just for like, hey, I wish there was a way to find out, I guess. Yes, and his house is amazing. His house is in a main through fare where they have a lot, like they have the shops built into the old buildings
and you go in and the doorways are really tiny and low and it's beautiful. It's really, it's a magical place. All right, so then we're in New York and we're starting to get- Waitressing. We're waitressing and who are your contemporaries at that age? Like, is there somebody that's still going right now
that you kind of came up with, actor-wise or actress-wise? Well, everyone that was my contemporary was waiting tables with me, so I had no contemporary in New York City. I was a waitress. All right. Well, like, did you battle anybody roles back then that you're still battling today?
I didn't audition. I was just, I had backstage, I don't know if, is that still around, backstage magazine in New York? I think so, yeah. You know what, have the ads and I would find what was appropriate and I'd hit the ground during the day
and, you know, there's room full of pervs or something was legit and you either ran or you stayed for, you know, an audition and- Where were you waitressing? Canestells on 19th and Park. It's not there anymore. And how did you like that?
How did you like that? Were you any good as a waitress or did you hate it? Well, I was, I started off in coachech and then I was upgraded to hostessing, which I was terrible at because I had to know everyone and really give preference to the special people and I didn't know who was special. And then they moved me to the cocktail lounge
where I ruled, I was amazing. I was amazing. Why? Because I gave people shit. Like I wasn't the cute waitress, I was just the smart ass. So I knew what people liked, that I would have it ready for them,
they would bring their clients in, I would really work it for them and then I'd get a great tip because I really treated the clients, you know, in a special way and I could just handle that. Yeah, they get all banged up. They want a saucy, sassy waitress. Lots of banging.
Yeah, we got it. All right, we got so many good quotes on this. Your publicist must be in a deep sweat right now, just off camera. How far off camera is your publicist with the headphones? 25 feet, but she's been with me for so long, she's just numb to it now. She's just, as long as I've not killed or maimed anyone,
she's like, she's fine. All right, so now you're telling me you did not audition for, because I want to know if there wasn't audition for this, I want to know how it went, speed. Oh, audition, but not until I moved to LA. Like I got off, off Broadway things and then somehow did NYU films, little films
and cobbled together a little real and somehow got an agent and then did TV, got some TV gigs and... What'd you get on TV? It was one show I can't remember, but it was with Major Healy. Remember from my dream of Jeannie, he was a vet. Sure I do.
Like it was a weird, I don't even remember, but... Was Major Healy Larry Hagman's friend or was he... Yes, yes. Roger, wasn't it Roger? I don't remember his name. Roger Healy. I thought he was great.
Then I moved to LA for work, but it was also a boy. And then I just started auditioning. Yeah, stop right there. Will likes to hear about all the love affairs. You can't just skip over the me. Don't pull your chair in. Let's get into this. Let's dig in, let's dig in.
So there's a boy. So you moved out to be here with... You moved out with him? Just for summer, I was just gonna be here for two months. That's all the money I had really earned on the last gig. And then I just auditioned and then started getting little tiny things here and there. And then it all fell apart.
Yeah. And then the career went right down the toilet. Yeah, right down the crapper. All right, so, but wait. So you were auditioning. So was there an audition for Speed? Yeah, big time. Okay, I'll just picture you in a folding chair.
That's exactly what it was. Pretending to be pressing on gas and then break. With a fake steering wheel. No way, fake steering. And sweet Keanu Reeves standing, like really trying to help me and do the scene. And then somehow we landed on the floor in a heap, you know, from the scene.
And I was all schmitzing and flop sweaty and it was... Wait, was he in there with you? Yeah. Oh my God. So it was kind of the camera's turning too. I was sweating so badly. And that shit is so weird. Isn't that so weird doing that?
It's so odd. Will, I had to do that with Amy, with Polar. For, we were gonna do a movie together. And I remember we auditioned together and I feel like, I don't think we had to kiss in it, but I remember there was like... Wait, not heartbreak. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Really? Yeah. And we are in there in the room together. I just remember it being super hot and sweaty. Like, this is weird auditioning with a friend. I mean, that's weird. Like having to audition in general, but intimately pretend like you are with a friend.
With your buddy's wife. I can't, can't. Well, like, have you, I'm sure you've had to have a romantic, have you ever had to have a friend play your husband or a boyfriend in a film? No. Good.
Like if I had to fight with you? Yes, I could do that. Sandy, if you and Jason had to do this like... This is gonna hurt my feelings. Epic love story. No, no, no. I would ask Amanda to come in. I'd put a wig on her and let you guys go at it.
And then I would be the part where I broke out it. Cause I feel that it's wrong. I would feel so wrong. I couldn't. Because you gotta sell it. But it's not real. Are you worried that if you got in that thing and you guys had to have this love thing
and kiss each other and look at each other. Are you worried you'd fall in love with Jason? Are you worried you'd fall in love with Jason? It's, there's a high risk. It's tough. Sandy, what if it was a love scene between me and you? That I would nail it. I would nail it.
I would be so good. Sean, I would be so good. You would question all of your decisions in life. I'm questioning them right now. You're claiming that you're claiming that Sean would question everything after it. He would question everything. He wouldn't change it.
I didn't say he would change it. But it would confuse me. It would confuse me. This is actually really. Confusing feelings. It's nice. What about, well, now you've done both. What about us?
Yeah. Well, that's good. And that's going to be what it is. That's going to be fireworks. That is everything that nothing else was. And that became. Well, you don't need to give her the hot eyes. What are you talking about?
What are you doing hot eyes? You guys are so small. Come in closer. Let me see the hot eyes. Well, just lean in for a second. Lean in. Y'all just gotta pretend there's a fire in the room. Yeah, there we go.
Okay, fire in the room. Tons of smoke in the room. That's so gross. Jesus. Is that in your eyes? Because you look tired. Jesus. You know what?
I got that today. Do I really look tired? I'm joking. I'm just picking up on you. I know. I know. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
I want to ask something, Jay. I want to ask something about the speed. It's called the speed. It's the speed. The speed. So obviously that's the movie. Everybody references that kind of gave you your start. It did, yeah.
Yeah, for sure. See, I feel like you were a big star before that. I know me too. Am I wrong about that? Like while you were sleeping was huge. I auditioned for that. But that was after. That was after.
Oh, after it. Okay. And so while you were making the speed, did you know like that classic question, did you know like in the moment where you're like, this is fucking awesome. People are going to go crazy. No, we were on a bus.
There was a bomb on the bus. We were on the, you know, doing circles at the airport in an unused part of the airport. Were you at LAX? Did you guys shoot that at LAX? We did. And then we were on the 105, that strip right before LAX. That hadn't been opened yet.
Right. And we was just, I mean, the Keanu was crazy famous. And then there was me and the crew on the bus. And we just kind of all hung out together. It was, you know, we were the bomb on the bus movie. It was Yandabot, who was a cinematographer. So you were not a star yet. So Keanu had, it was a Keanu Reeves above the title.
Keanu Reeves. Absolutely, Keanu Reeves. And then a bus flying in the background. And a bus. Like the bus was above the title too. And there was a stunt driver in my dress in a wiglet. No. Behind the wheel of, yes.
He was about 220 in that little slip dress and a little bang. So if you look closely, I think they've somehow inserted me in some places, but it's just, it should have been all Keanu and all bus. There's no Sandy was needed. Wow. Now, all right.
So that sounds like a fairly manageable, somewhat easy shoot. In comparison to, let's go all the way forward into, let's say gravity, where there's tons of green screen. You got to pretend that you're seeing everything. And it was just stunningly well done by you and them. Martha Graham. Everything was Martha Graham.
Was that, now, which is easier? Working with a bus that you can see and feel or green screen? Well, the hard part about the bus was, I would be up in the front seat driving and there would be some guy in the back pretending to be someone else actually maneuvering the bus as they're plowing into things.
So I had absolutely no control over the bus. So that was, that was freaky. I've done something like that before. Very scary. You've done that before, Jay? Yeah, I had to like drive into oncoming traffic and they built a car where the guy up on the roof of the car, they had a cage up there.
Yeah, we had that too. Right, so he's actually driving and I'm down in the driver's seat and the camera's behind me in the back seat and it looks like I'm driving but the guy on the roof is actually driving and we're driving 60 miles an hour into oncoming traffic on a freeway.
That's all timed out where I go left, the other car goes right, but I'm not doing the driving. So I'm, I have to just trust that this guy's gonna be on it. Otherwise, I have a head on collision 30 times, you know. I gotta go back and rewatch a little house in the prairie. I don't remember. Well, yeah.
Sean, that's how you and Scotty, when you go to Chin Chin twice and you get Scotty's on the roof, right? Do you mean Chin Chin, the restaurant? Yeah, you know that. That has that, the chicken salad with the extra crunchies on top. That's right, we eat it so often
that Scotty framed it as double chins. Yeah, that's what you mean. So, there you go. But wait, wait, wait, wait, finish what you're gonna say about gravity because gravity's one of my favorite movies of all time and you were amazing in it and you won the Oscar and I presented you with the People's Choice Award.
I didn't, I didn't. You didn't win the Oscar. Let me finish. You didn't win the Oscar for that, but you were nominated for it. Yeah, yeah. She won for blindside. That's right.
We're gonna get to that. But so, so, so we're on, so we're on the spaceship. So we're on the spaceship. So we're in space. That's a green. We're on the rocket here and someone says, so when you went to space, how was it to film? And we were in Alfonso and I were like,
we weren't in space. Oh boy. You know what, it was a really profound time for me in that I was going through some things and I then was on this journey with the great Alfonso Cuaron where it was just me. And Clooney banging on the window trying to get in. Clooney trying to get in.
Clooney's always trying to get in. Another quote. And then I had to cut him loose and let him die so I could have a screen time. It just was, it was amazing because everything that I did up to that point, like in my childhood with dance and music and counting and all the things musically that happened and physically that happened
in my life, incorporating music came into play in order to do this. Cause I'd either be on a bicycle seat with one leg strapped to it and the rest of my body. So I could move in slow mode. I think you guys are watching me. It's like Martha Graham. So I had to, they said this point here is this is Soyuz.
This is George. This is so you have 10 seconds to get from here to there. Is this contraption move? So I had to move my body like I was swimming in slow motion while my voice got to move normally. So it was isolating. It was beautiful. I saw the making of it.
It was incredible. It's really emotional. Like, and you have, you have Chivo who is an extraordinary cinematographer just trying to figure out technology as we were shooting basically. And we didn't know what it was. We had two previews and they were not great.
Really? Because the effects weren't in, the music wasn't in. You saw, you know, lines and it just felt, oh my God. I'm coming out of, I thought there's a rebirth for me. I felt good. Life was on the uptick and then I saw the preview and I was like, oh my God, this is going to tank. I just, I'm just going to go back home with my baby
and we're just going to stay put. And how was the early stuff? Like, as it was approaching the release date listener, there's a thing called tracking where you can sort of like get a sort of like a hint as to how the movie's going to perform based on how much the public is aware of it. Was that all stuff good?
No, I honestly don't know because I didn't get the sense that we had, I mean, I had the most profound experience of my career, just the personal life mixed with the kindest people being in England, just, you know, like, it was just beautiful, all things kind of helped healing. And then not until we went to the Venice Film Festival, which was sort of a blur to begin with,
fittings in your hair and not have to get on a boat, what I have to look over my shoulder, what I have to, I'm not good at any of that. I just want to implode and hide in a corner. Jason, you know, I don't leave the house. Which is so surprising to me because you're incredibly charismatic and friendly. With people I feel safe with.
But you also, but you know how to make people who you don't know and they don't, you, you know how to make them feel safe. Like you have incredible people skills. But that's with human beings. That's with people. I don't want a camera point. I don't want to be looked at that way.
And I don't. Like dissected, yeah. Don't tell her what she's good at. She's telling you. Thank you, well, thank you. Yeah, let hers be. Good, no, thank you, well. No, please don't.
Do you connect with Sean at all? Do you feel any connection? Because he feels like a camera, like he's like a robot, right? No, look at him. He's just walking joy. Sean is just walking joy. Thank you.
I didn't know Sandy other than our love for each other. I didn't know how much we had in common with the music and the opera and the. No, here we go. Five, six, seven, eight. Ba, na, na, na. I really need this job. Could you guys harmonize right now?
No. Yes, let's try it. I'll bet you could. No. Now, how do you do that? Somebody starts to know. I can't flop sweat right now, you guys. I have to finish this press tour.
I can't, my pores can't open and ooze. And just mess up the 12 hours of hair and makeup that went into this day. Harmonizing would make you sweat. It would make me sweat. Yeah, any kind of singing. See, you guys have radio voices. I have a not a voice for radio.
We have radio faces is what we got. Now, Sandy, sadly, there's a classic question an interviewer probably would ask, probably something like Sean would ask, but I'm going to ask a different way. The common question would be, what have you done that you would like to do? My question is, what have you done
because you don't want to do it and that's never going to change. You're not ever, like for me, it would be Shakespeare. I'd be way too scared to do that. I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. So what about it for you? Is it singing and dancing?
Singing, dancing, dancing, yes. Singing, no. That's so crazy. It's such a big part of your life. I bet you can sing and you're being. I'm telling you, I can carry a tune. I can hum any. I just remember my dad saying,
cause he was such an incredible teacher. He would travel between New York and DC and he'd taught people at the Met and he would fix voices and teach them from the diaphragm and he'll voices and he says, you can have a five octave range. It doesn't matter if you cannot express yourself through song.
People can sound like a car backed over them and have more to say with their voice. I can't. So your dad talked about music. He was a musician, very talented. Like to talk about all that kind of, I mean, imagine having a father, or just having a father who was around,
but having one who also could talk about music, something that you're really interested in. Well, my mother and my mother had a voice like Maria Callas. My mother sounded like Maria Callas. She had the most exquisite voice in the power behind her stillness. And she was exquisite. It was a king's art.
It's a king's art. Sean, are you crying right now? Sorry. A little bit on the inside. Sean, so Sandy, what you don't know? Sean's father drove away from him doing about 130 in a domestic six back in the passenger seat. Right?
Really? Yeah, it was five years old. No, wait, Sandy, I'm gonna sing something you're gonna say. I'm really sad right now. I'm gonna sing something you're gonna say in the name of the opera, ready? Okay. Quand du min vo, quand du min vo,
quand du min vo, solet, la perra, la ria. Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun. I don't know the name, but I know the two. Well, your mom had to have sang that. Well, not like, but nice voice, Sean. I know, it's beautiful. I know, Sean, it's really good. Really nice.
Sean, do you do parties? I'm so glad. Here's the sad part. Yes. Now, here's another one. And both this goes for Sean and or Sandy. Who said this great quote? You ready?
I like a show to unfold and keep presenting itself, surprising you. Jason Bateman? No, don't you dare. No, Sean. Wait, say it again. I like a show to unfold and keep presenting itself, surprising you.
Sean said this. David Blaine. Tommy Toon. So look. Oh. We always told my sister that was really her father. My mother had an affair with Tommy Toon. Cause she was so tall.
So you didn't feel any pressure or obligation to try singing? No. My dad and mom taught in the house at first before they had their studios. And my dad used to bring me down as a kid and like hit a high C and I would belt it out and go back upstairs. But I think when your parents have such a rigorous
artistry like they did, the practicing, everything that sounds came out of our basement in the neighborhood kids thought we were insane. I was, it was shame. My mother was a hottie and she had all these and then she would sing opera. And it was just shame and embarrassment for me. I wanted to know.
She does sound hot. She, my mother was absolutely gorgeous. And she knew it. Was going into acting a bit of a make good on your part or was there a passion from you? Going into acting was the comedy aspect. Like I lived for Jerry Lewis. I lived for Mrs. O'Eagans.
You know, it's like I lived for any comedy that was. Well, here, here's one of the things. So Jason said it. And so he was saying, you know, you're so, you're so good with people and you're so charismatic, which is all very true. One of the things is, is that you connect with people with audiences.
No, it's true. You connect with audiences in this way because, and you're so good and you're so funny because you are very vulnerable on screen, whether you're doing a comedy or you're doing a drama. And which is, which is rare. And you can do any, you're very rare that you can do anything.
So now, so as I say that, I'm thinking like, well, you've done so many great comedies, you've done action, you've done dramas, you've won Academy Awards, you've won everything. What is it in sort of the opposite of what Jason was asking? Well, not what are you scared of. What is that thing that's kind of out there for you? What's your 100 foot wave?
What's the thing that you're chasing? My kids. Yeah. I just wanna not be anywhere that takes me away from seeing they're growing. I really had on this last thing that I did, I just said something in my head, I was like, I feel like this is the last one for a while.
Wow. And I was like, because all I wanna do is just watch them become, and it's happening right now. And I'm sure the pandemic has something to do with that. Everything is so shut down and fear-based. And I just literally, I've had the luck of the draw and that I've been at the right place at the right time. I have a really strong work ethic that I know I have.
And the rest of it is luck and timing. And I just don't wanna be anywhere that I go, I just wish I was with my kids wherever they need to go right now. Not in a helicoptery thing, but I'm lucky in that I can pay my bills. I've saved, I love my real estate. I love architecture.
I've always planned to have the rug pulled out, so I'm fine. I just wanna watch them grow up and I don't- I feel the same way. Every job now I look at, I look at, the first thing I think is, is this worth taking, even if it's in town, is this job worth taking in terms of hours
that I'm gonna spend, late nights, whatever it is, or missing early mornings, is it gonna be worth it being away from my kids for this? And the answer is always yes. It's always yes. I'm sure you would say, because Louie is now what? 11. 11, 15.
He's 11 going on 12th in December. God, he seems older. I know, he's wise, he's a wise- And Lila is nine? Eight going on nine. Okay, so, well, I'm super close on that. For me, that's real close. That's bullseye.
Amanda's gonna lose it when she hears this. She's so high. Don't tell Amanda I missed it. Now- I've got her, she's on speaker. I'm sure you'll say that every age has been, but what do you like most about this age that they're going through now?
Because for me, I feel like you can find out, because there's so much better with language and feelings, you can find out much more accurately what's going on inside of them than when they're obviously two or three years old. Yeah, yeah. Do you love that part of it? Or do you prefer the sort of the bottle and the pacifier
and the diapers and- No, no, no, no, no. I mean, that to me was amazing. I wish now I could go back and have a moment knowing now what I know with them in that stage. So it wasn't, cause I was in a state of panic. I just, I felt like I had so much fear at that time that I missed out on the sweetness of that.
Fear of doing the wrong thing as a mom? Sure, and there was just a lot of stuff going on in my life at that time. And that just, I was running and I was in protection mode, and I just felt like the world was coming in and I just wanted to protect them. And I felt guilt that it was coming in on them. And now that I look back, I go, why are we using worried?
But it's, you know, 2020. But I love where they are now in the sense that Louis is like a 78 year old philosopher in an 11 year old's body who can talk to you philosophically and empathetically about life on a junior level of high school. Just put just, he says profoundly kind and evolved things. Yet he's obsessed with Naruto and Spider-Man
in the Spider-Verse. He's appropriately balanced and jumped. But that's the, we're passing in Jago. That was pre-pandemic when you were at the house through the charcuterie. He's not moved on to it. Jason's like an 11 year old intellect in a 78 year old body.
So it's kind of like, you just gotta spend some time with your son because I mean it's- Sandra, Sandy. Yes. So I just, a quick question. You mentioned that, you know, you said Jason, you know that I don't like to go out and stuff like that, that I understand
just from a human standpoint. Nevermind being as, you know, gigantically famous public person like you are. You don't say gigantic to a woman. Sorry. Like Marvin Short. But do you ever just miss going to the grocery store just like, you know, going-
And I do that in places where it's not LA. Like I love roaming up and down the aisles of a grocery store and buying a massive amount of things and you go, I'm going to try this. I'm going to use this for this. And then you have like 17 jarred items that you'll never touch. But you go, but one day if I should need it,
those campers are right there. Right. But you're a home body. I'm just a home. I love being outside. I'm not a shut-in. I love being outside. I love hiking.
I love being- You are great about going out. You call yourself somebody who's staying at home all the time, but you're great about going out for somebody as high profile as you. You keep telling her what she is and she keeps telling me- Wait, guys, stop telling me who I should be. I get the sense that, let me finish.
I get the sense that you're great at going out. But think about when we've gone out. Yes. What has been the catalyst to go out for us when we go out? The kids, every single time. But the way that you go out, you're not always looking over your shoulder worried about,
you're comfortable being out and about. Yeah, totally, totally, totally. Yes, I just, I'm comfortable in normal settings. I'm not comfortable when you're on a red carpet or when you are- Oh, right, right. When I can talk to people, I love it because I learned something.
I can be myself. It's my brain. I'm comfortable with my brain. But it's a weird, I was just showing, you're looking over your shoulder, keep going, is the paparazzi here yet? Are they here yet? But you were like, because he had called them.
And then he just called you. I mean, that's what you do. You call them when you're at the post office looking your worst. You do that. Are they here? They're just like us. I was on vacation in Paris once,
the only time I've ever been in Paris. And I was staying at this fancy hotel and the Rolling Stones were staying at the same time. And every day there was a barricade of thousands of people across the street. And just as I exited the hotel, I turned to my friends and I'd go, oh, I'm so sorry. And I'd open the door and I'd wave to everybody.
And one flash would go off. It would just go blink. And they've used that photo over and over again. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. Now let's get to Unforgivable right now. This thing looks, can we say badass on the radio? If you say it like, it looks badass.
It looks badass. It looks badass. It will, will for the win. Now, you didn't waste a lot of time in wardrobe fittings and hair and makeup tests. Now, would that, that was a relief. You know, she plays a, she plays an ex-con guys. She's coming out of jail and she doesn't care
about the hair and the makeup and the clothes. She doesn't give a shit. That's how the, Ruth Slater, she doesn't give a shit. In a world. This Christmas, Sandy Bullock doesn't give a shit. Right? Now, you don't, do you, you do care a lot or a little about the, about, about the fact that there's a lot.
I need to listen. Sorry. Sorry. The whole, the whole glam, the, the unfortunate necessary glam side of, of the female side of this business, which I think is dog shit. Of course you care when you're on a red carpet and you look like shit.
It's like. But if you have to do that every day for your part. I couldn't. I couldn't. I couldn't. That's what I loved about, what I loved about. That's what I loved. Just sound it out.
About what I loved about what I loved. Do you get it? Yeah. That sounds like it. I love physical comedy. None of it is beautiful. None of it required beauty. It like, it translates all.
My mother was German, had no sense of humor. And then one day. Speak to that, Sean. She's looking at you. How many doesn't require beauty? Go ahead, Sean. But it doesn't. It doesn't require you to be insanely attractive.
And as long as you are able to make an ass of yourself. And my mother was the hardest person to make laugh. And but if I got injured, she thought it was hysterical, she's German. So I realized that physical comedy was one way of making everyone around me comfortable because I automatically look like the ass and they couldn't make me feel like an ass
because I already did it first. It was not very surprising considering that the Germans are the people who invented a word for taking pleasure in other people's. Schadenfreude. Yeah. So, but this film, but the unforgivable December 10th. Yes, December 10th on Netflix.
Is not a comedy. Make no mistake, right? But you're saying like a comedy. This Christmas, Sandra Fuller could give two fucks. So like a comedy, you need not worry about all the glam in this. So like a comedy, you need not worry about all the glam in this because it's a badass drama. Yes?
Yeah, it's a family drama, but it's also mixed in sort of a murder. I mean, look, I look at it, I go, I like to entertain. So I don't want to find a subject matter that I feel I need to hit people over the head with. I want something that people go, what the fuck just happened here? Why did she do that?
What kind of person is this? And within that is a story of just, does this woman deserve forgiveness and redemption? Some people say no. And then it's just, I just love the combination of the two. I love that you go, okay, what does someone who's eating themselves alive from the inside out look like?
How do we get there? So you just want to entertain and make people feel something, you know? What about the concept of like Bird Box? Was that the last Netflix film that you did? Bird Box wasn't originally at Netflix. It was at Universal where Stuber was at that time. And that's what it was going to be.
And then he moved. And Scott said, let's drag it over here. And he moved to Netflix and he said, what do you think? And I went, I like trying new things. I like that, I mean, look, as a woman, I'm just surprised I'm still working and it's a nice place to be. But I like the idea of it working at Netflix
because the boys got to do it. The girls hadn't done it yet. Do you feel that thing you just touched on it? You're a woman and you're happy to be still working. Do you feel that thing of like there's less and less roles for women, for you? No, I feel there's more and more and more. Good, that's great.
Because of streaming, because of everything out there. And look, I'd always planned for the rug to be pulled out much earlier on. That's why my first love, which is restoration and real estate and all that was where my money went. Every penny went into there to build that for the kids if they ever want to take it over. And I had something to fall back on that.
I loved just as much, if not more, at times. So I didn't want to be left without my creative juices being able to be used. And I'm just surprised that I'm like, okay, this must be my last one. Wait, it's not. So if you were not, well, if they kicked you out of the business tomorrow,
would you be an interior designer, an architect, or a realtor? Restorer, or restore, and I like finding properties, finding out what the story is, getting it back to the vibe that I feel it wants to be and finding its use and purpose. All the places that I have are used and it's just, I get to still have the thing
that I love and spent two and a half years getting to the place that it should be or should have been. So it's not a redo, it's a restore, mostly. Pretty much, pretty much, yeah. I love that. I love that. That's pretty cool.
And you'll rent these? Mm-hmm. Yeah. I love it. Or lease, lease. What's the difference between a rent and a lease? Well, it depends on what they are. Some are homes, some are buildings,
some are, you know, it's, I just love the history of architecture that in our country, I think we're so quick to take away. And I think the thing about Europe is you can walk around and you feel the history. I think that's why I love New Orleans so much. I just watched a documentary on PBS about Paul Williams. Oh my gosh.
I looked for Paul Williams' home for so long when it was just me and Lou, and I said, how amazing would it be if the home that I find in LA when I was moving from Austin would have been a Paul Williams' home? Like, you know, he used to draw the plans upside down because his clients who were white and he was not,
he felt they wouldn't want to sit next to him, so he learned how to draw his plans upside down. I know, it's fascinating. It's incredible. And then he went into songwriting and did some of the acting stuff. And what about his cameo in Cannonball Run with Havocorn?
Short people, obviously. Short people got, you know, is that noise? You wore a lot of hats. They got a little bitty hat. Did any of that strike a chord there, Jason, as I'm singing Havocorn Baby? Yes, oh, that's my father-in-law. That's your father-in-law.
And he's, you know, I gotta get him on the show. God damn it. You haven't had him on the show? Who's your father-in-law? Tell, say who it is. His name is Paul Anka. And he's a pillar of the music industry. Will, I'm gonna explain it all to you after this episode.
He's Canadian, I know exactly who he is. I wanna say, you know, when you said you only do projects that keep you close to your family, which I totally admire and totally get, do they ever come visit and hang out with you? And do they, do they get excited about it? Are they like, this looks boring? Louis gets really excited about craft service.
But since it's COVID hit, there is no craft service. So he's absolutely disinterested in anything that I have to do. Lila, on the other hand, is going to no doubt either be president of the United States or be in the entertainment industry. She is. Wow, she's a force.
She's sharp, she's such a powerhouse. So like what, I remember thinking, my kids will never be in the business. And then I was like, why not? Wait, I told her, I said, wait till you're 18. I want you to be baked. I don't want you to be a child. But I said, after you turn 18,
this is something that you really want, then absolutely. That's really smart. But I want you to be a kid. I want you to have that. We know what it looks like to be a kid on a set. And it's hard. It's hard, yeah, Jason. Look at me, I'm a mess.
Talk about it, just talk about it. This incredible maternal instinct that you have, it didn't come from having a shitty upbringing. And so you want to make things right for your kids. It came because you had a great upbringing, yes? And you wanted to keep it going? Well, I always knew that I would be a mom. I always knew.
And I think my mother saw it and she kept me under lock and key. And I was like, you know, it's very true. My mother was incredibly strict with me. I was not allowed in a car or at a car date or anything like that to be alone with anyone basically till I was 18. Because you were too horny?
Because she, you know, because I was a horn dog. Oh, what about your sister, not so much? Not so much, because Zina got away with murder. She did everything I didn't do. She snuck out, she did drugs, she tried all that stuff. But she was a brilliant student. But I was, I talked back, I questioned authority. I was, my sister told me later on in life,
she goes, you just didn't play the game right. You fought back. You should have just been the quiet, studious girl that I was, but I wasn't that way. So my mother thought I was just trouble and I didn't do anything. I did not, didn't even skip school. I did nothing.
So I just came from a very sheltered life. I knew that I wanted kids, I loved kids, but I didn't want them any time now. I like boys too much. I wanted to go through that Rolodex. Let me ask you this. Do you, as far as the business goes and it relates to family,
do you feel like, do you want to beat it to the punch and leave while you're ahead? Or do you want to work until you know you can't work any longer? Neither, really. I don't, I always think, I'm literally like, the last one I said, this is probably my last one in a long time, just because that's where I am.
And look, that could be a flop or it could be amazing. I think it's gonna be great fun, but you don't know and I just, I don't know because I sort of just kind of go with where my joy is at that time. And I was like, what if I take, what if I just don't work for a while and I want to come back and they don't let me in?
And they go, so they don't let you in? So what's the deal? Like I don't want this business to be, To define you. To define me or to make me anxious if it isn't there for me anymore. That's what I'm striving for, is to just, Your spot will always be saved for you
because you're not, you're not, You'll give me a spot. You're not a success because you're beautiful. You're not a success because you're funny. You're not a success because of all of those things. So in other words, you're not gonna age out or time out or talent out of anything. On top of all that,
you're also producing a ton of stuff too. And with all your set experience, you'd probably be an incredible director as well. I don't want to direct. I have no desire to direct. No, no, no. I mean, I just want to go home. I just want to go home.
Producing, I'm there anyway. So the producing I love because it's control. It's like, if it's, I don't want anyone to sink my ship but me. Directing, you are responsible. I don't want to be responsible for anything other than that, which allows me to go home to my family. Right.
I love that. So then you're probably, you're probably one take, two takes, Sandy's got it. No, no, no, no. Do you need a lot of takes? I like to come out of the gate prepared. Cause I don't want to waste time. And you know when the clock is ticking.
So I mean, that's where once you learn what production is about, most actors don't. And you go, oh, that's money. Oh, that's time. You come prepared. I have a really strong work ethic, probably cause I'm German. I know how lucky I am.
I don't want to waste people's time. I want to give myself every opportunity within the, within the allotted time, you know, and not have someone go, well, we couldn't get it. Let's move on. And I'm like, I panic. Are you a first take person? With drama, yes.
With drama, yes. And are you a wait, save it for the closeup with drama? I've learned to do that because once I realized, I was like, wait a minute. What do you mean? We're in a wide. I'm just, I'm, I'm spent. And for Tracy in Wisconsin,
that means that usually when you shoot a scene, you'll shoot the scene in a wider and then they'll move in and you'll get pieces where you'll cover each actor. And they call that coverage. And Sandy. So when you're... So hang on, I'm just explaining for your sister.
Sean, I'm talking to your sister. Okay, go ahead, sir. And, and so if, if, if Sandy Bullock is doing a very emotional dramatic scene, Tracy, you, she's got to emote. Okay. Hang on. Hang on.
Sorry, hang on. Tracy, Tracy. She's all narcoleptic. She's getting some milk from the fridge. Tracy, right here, right here. She probably is getting milk. Okay. So, and now she's back.
And so she has to keep that, in order to give that performance she wants to give, she wants to give it in the close-up, which is the, the, the size that they're gonna probably cut you in that a moment, in that moment. So Sandy, I have a question. When you're in England and you're shooting and you don't nail it on the first take,
do you go, Bullocks, Bullocks, Crikey, Crikey. No, he was doing your last name. He was trying to sneak it, sneak in. Oh, Bullocks, oh, I get it, I get it. This is the host of the year, Sandy. He is. Will, we'll let him let it go. Okay, we can't.
The world's all time greatest, no, what is his reward? My favorite moment that he did. He played a little stick for women in film. Years ago, my sister and I were there and he's at the piano. And he was the only one that called it what it was. He goes, whiff. No, right, no, but it was, it was women in film,
partnerships in entertainment, was the full thing. So women in film, partnerships in entertainment, and I wrote a song to Coldplay and I sang it using different words and I called it whiff of pie. It was brilliant, that's right, whiff of pie. See, he did something for the ladies. That's right, I always do stuff for the ladies,
I love the ladies. He's a song and dance man. We've kept Sandy book way too long, she's way too important. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Not even, I've made my way through a pack of these. Oh, the Whoppers. Oh, Whoppers, she likes her candy.
This is when you know you're in a press junket. Caffeine, green tea, and Whoppers, this is. Sandy, we love you. Thank you so much for saying yes and squeezing us in on this. I love you so, so, so much. You know what, thank you for, I'm so proud of you and your wife is amazing.
Amanda, Amanda, Amanda, Amanda Enka. She's birthed him, two of the most extraordinary young women I've had the pleasure of watching grow up. Jason, wait til you meet these kids of yours. Remind me of their names. They're incredible. I'm gonna probably see your daughter tomorrow. Tell her how.
My house, you know she comes to my house for like, play dates, right? She's in love with Lila. Yeah, well, they're cut from the same cloth. And we're in love with you. Thank you for saying yes. Have a great rest of your day. Thank you guys, thank you, thank you.
All right, get your flag back up in front of the camera or slam the laptop close or whatever. Oh, do I have to? Really, what is it? Yeah, let your freak flag fly for sure. Ready? There it is. It was so good to see you guys and I'll feed a zine.
Oh! Bye, Sandy. Look at that. All right. Bye, honey, thank you, love you. Bye, guys. Bye. She's sunlight.
She's sunlight, right? That's a movie star, right? That's a movie star. Yeah. And also simultaneously a very real grounded cool person. Well, that's why she's a star. You know, we should, we book a few of those, I think because the three of us are allergic to the other,
but we should book the other. We should get a real SOB in here. We should. She's great. I didn't know all that stuff about her background and... Yeah, yeah. Did you know that before, Jason? Before you were...
Wikipedia, no. No. Or the opera singer stuff or any of that. So cool. Oh. Yeah. Or the ages of her kids. Or any of that stuff.
Yeah. Huh. Listen, I don't, I just, I see the eyes. I see the eyes and the heart. Okay. I just see eyes and heart. Eyes and heart. Eyes and heart.
That's my name. Eyes and heart's the title. Yeah, yeah, George Eisenhardt. George Eisenhardt. Anyway, more like that, please. She was fabulous. Fantastic. No, she's incredible.
Are you guys thinking about a bye right now? Cause I am. I think we should just say it. You know what, do we have a next, we have a show next week, right? Or do we have a bye? Bye. Bye.
A bye week. Bye. Bye. Smart. What. Smart. What. SmartLess is 100% organic
and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. SmartLess. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts
or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.